les jeux des îles représente beaucoup
parce que ça fait quelques années déjà
que je suis investi 2003 à maurice en
laser déjà c'était la première fois
qu'il y avait des lasers aux jeux des
îles
une expérience incroyable j'ai adoré
déjà parce que on a rencontré des
coureurs d'autres îles qui n'ont pas les
mêmes moyens que nous parce qu'il ya
quand même un partage de matériel à
effectuer à chaque jeux des îles
il y en a qui sont devenus des amis
depuis que je vois toujours des
mauriciens et des seychellois et puis
j'ai fait ceux de 2011 aux seychelles à
un grand moment
un grand moment déjà sur l'eau parce
qu'on a la chance quand même de naviguer
sur des plans d'eau exceptionnel
magnifique on a les tortues qui nagent à
côté nous c'est enrichissant pour tout
le monde j'espère en tout cas on échange
des anneaux façon de naviguer en échange
nos façons de vivre moi je crois que si
les filles on a un message à faire
passer il ya très peu de filles qui
naviguent dans nos îles c'est un sport
un peu tabou parce que les filles si
elles sont a disposé à se mettre à l'eau
c'est culturel et donc j'espère que en
nous voyant naviguer de ça va
interpeller d'autres filles et à la
réunion et dans les îles de l'océan
indien quelles qu'elles soient pas ce
qu'on voit à la télé aux jeux olympiques
on a l'impression de vivre un petit peu
ce sont comme des mini jeux olympiques
on est quand même sous couvert du comité
olympique est en tout cas pour moi c'est
ça c'est assez émouvant et on fait on a
l'impression
j'étais aux jeunes impliqués